Robert James fer was quite simply a
phenomenon he broke every record in the
book during a meteoric rise to the top
of his sport chess having scaled the
chess equivalent of Mount Everest to
become the Undisputed best player on
earth Fisher threw it all away as his
growing paranoia and distrust saw him
all but abandon the game he dedicated
his life to as his behavior grew more
and more eratic he practically became a
recluse and not an awful lot has known
about his movements over the following
decades though he did get himself
involved in a doomsday cult called the
worldwide Church of God his first
competitive game after two decades in
the wilderness was held in 1992 in
Yugoslavia Fischer won but he also got
himself into trouble with the law there
was a United Nations embargo against
commercial activities in Yugoslavia and
the match was deemed to be a violation
not ke who faced a Fallout that awaited
him in America fiser would never again
return to his homeland